and we're back with the rose-petal
podcast meeting with Nikki Glaser a
permanent judge and the firing squad
this season Nikki what was your first
what was your reaction when they asked
you to be a permanent judge this season
oh my god I was at lunch with my friends
after I was doing my radio show on
Comedy Central radio it's called you up
on Sirius XM channel 1995 and um
afterwards we were having lunch and I
got a call from whenever you get a call
from both your agent and manager on the
same call it's either great news or
terrible news and I have a lot of heat
on me now so I was like this is good
news so I know they can't fire me again
yeah I went out onto the street and they
asked me they said they want you to be a
judge on rose-petal and I was like hell
yes I was very excited and um and then
they told me how much money I was making
and I was like no I was even more
excited but then they they hadn't given
me the roasts yet at that point so I was
laying I was kind of waiting for that
call you know the roast of Bruce Willis
and so I was like oh this probably means
I'll get the roast of Bruce Willis which
it didn't mean that but I was just like
I should start like it just meant a lot
to me in many different ways because I
was like oh this means back on board
like a number one rated radio show in
like the history of this other station
so I mean well you know it's it's I'm
I'm my show is killing it and that's
radio though but I did have a TV show on
the network and right you know cancelled
so two seasons though yeah it was I mean
it wasn't cancelled because it wasn't
good or you know there's lots of who
cares
but the point of the matter is I'm back
in bed with Comedy Central we are you
know it's like when you get back with an
ex which is all I do
and it's like that's how I feel about
Comedy Central it's like I'm like in
this phase of like we're in love again
we'll break each other's hearts at some
point because everything comes to an end
but right now it's it's it's real good
you really like roasted what you really
like roasting do I like like roasting I
love it
yes yeah because it's joke writing it's
just great joke writing and you get to
be really mean which I feel at my core I
am but I never
really get to be okay and and you get to
be really dark you ended some of those
jokes is like really dark cuz
you're a dark guy even though you're so
cheery I know that there's a deep
sadness within you I do and that's why
I'm giving you the win because I don't
want you to pull a Bourdin later tonight
so kill themselves that's what I'm
saying why do you feel you don't get to
be me well I just think in normal life
I'm not a mean person I just feel like I
like to make people comfortable and feel
good about themselves and that's kind of
what's true and I want that back at me
like just in life but I think mean
things all the time and i'm and also i'm
konstantine a judge is amazing cuz i'm
constantly judging people all the time
and i don't get to let any of that out
and in this role I get to do both Sarah
Tiana you proved tonight that women are
funny dolph ziggler you prove tonight
that butch lesbians are funny and that
means something to me you did you did
seem like a natural in judging yeah it
was it was a it was a talent I didn't
know I I had but I really enjoyed it but
I love roasting I think I wrote jokes
for friends who have been on previous
roasts like early on when I was a young
comic so I got certain jokes on it made
me feel so good and really validates you
as a joke writer and I think that's I
love joke writers like that's my
favorite kind of comedian is not ones
that you're like Wow his performances
you know I can respect a performance but
the writing is always what stands out to
me and that's what I like about the
process so I think that's what these
it's whittled down to just jokes like
Joe coughs it's that's what essentially
what it is mean Joe coughs it's awesome
we shop for three nights six episodes I
mean what did you learn through the
process I learned hmm what did I learn
I learned that there's a lot of talent
out there new talent coming up that I'm
like oh god dammit you know what I mean
like you see the new person on campus
and you're like oh god they're gonna
eclipse me someday and I'm gonna be
jealous of them and all that so I just
learned that there's like so much new
talent that I didn't know about you
sitting right here Pat Barker is
hilarious when I
lost a child I had to pray that one day
I'd be able to have another one when Eli
lost the child he had to pray that that
child didn't go to the police going into
it I really didn't know much about you
and I'm like oh great God he's really
good and thank you yeah it was um it was
cool to me I made so many friends this
week of shooting like I I come to LA I
used to live here until January and then
I moved to New York to do my show and um
and I when ever I come back I have like
two friends here I just like don't have
any la friends and now after this roast
battle experience I have so many more
friends close friends I've ones that you
judge for actually I really Nicole
Buchannon butt cannon yeah yeah love her
Connor McSpadden I just felt like I
didn't and you got like I got to know
you both of you I just feel like I know
so many more people and it was just a
really I want to do more episodes
because I loved the cast and I loved the
people that hung around and I loved the
community of it that's kind of what this
is all about it is a community project
the Rose it's a great I came up out of
Philadelphia and when I first moved out
here I didn't have any real sense of
community until I discovered the Rose
battle it's a tight group it is and
there's so much love there as much hate
as there is there there's so much love
and everyone and it's you know Jeff Ross
is like the nicest person ever and takes
care of other comics so well and I think
I taught other comics that he's taken
care of to take care of comics that
follow them and so I think it's just
it's it's all really nice good people I
don't think there's an asshole in the
bunch you don't you don't meet you don't
last if you're an asshole if you're not
fun and cool to be around you don't you
don't then we don't keep you around yeah
well you know they work their way out
yeah cuz everyone is that's like
everyone's sweet all you boys are so
sweet and it's not that's just not like
not every young male comic is sweet a
lot of them have egos and especially
when you're battling and there's winners
and losers there can be egos and I'm
that is all at play but you all are just
really kind and
and damaged people this is truly the
thing that I took away from this week
that I was so grateful for was that some
so many of the jokes were written about
really dark stuff you know about like
your marriage is falling apart with the
sklar's you know a lot of people ask us
how do you tell the two of us apart I
say it's easy Jason's the one in glasses
and I'm the one in a good marriage you
know what I mean like I didn't know that
I'm like oh wow like or or you've tried
to kill yourself before or you've had
miscarriages you guys had a miscarriage
after you'd already baby-proofed the
house it worked a baby didn't get in
there are things that people are not
talking about on television outside and
especially not in a personal way right
open enough to let someone make fun of
them for it I mean honestly what you're
doing is groundbreaking and I sense that
being there because I struggle with
depression and and suicidal thoughts and
all of those things and just see someone
get up there be like yeah I've tried to
kill myself and now I'm gonna let people
make fun of me for it it's like good
let's open the dialogue because there's
people watching at home who have also
have those thoughts who can't even admit
it let alone make fun of it and it's
just really empowering to watch someone
make fun of themselves about that stuff
after season two I got a bunch of
messages from people who have been
through miscarriages and they're like
they thought that was the the thing I
got most often in terms of feedback was
people being like that really took guts
I can't even like come out publicly like
my wife and I are hiding it and yeah I
think anytime you have something like
that and you just it's empowering it is
so important what you're doing and it's
and you found a way to do it in such a
fun entertaining way without getting too
serious but you're talking about issues
that literally no one else is talking
about on TV
yamaneika you just mean like we were
both molested and here's some jokes
about that that's important to people
who have been molested I
I haven't been and I'm almost angry
about it because I wanted to relate to
that on a different level it really was
an important joke and I'm grateful for
you tonight you know I made a joke on
the roast of Bruce Willis about Robin
Williams like not about him but you know
referencing that he killed himself but
people go oh and I go well are we not
supposed to like do you he killed
himself so if we don't talk about it
then it's taboo and then we don't talk
about suicide but talk about suicide and
actually people who are thinking about
it feel free enough to talk about it
maybe they won't do it exactly so we
need to talk about these things we need
to make fun of them and I congratulate
you on finding a really great way to do
it
[Applause]